and they're like you think we should
turn back I said we turn back with
turning back to jungle how the hell we
get another alternate again let's just
can we make it to Nicaraguan one so now
the alternator's was because we are
bladder right in those airplane you got
to have a big bladder which is you know
rubber like Goodyear used to make them
and then we have extra fuel and that and
the fuel would be pumped out to the
tanks so we will have longer range right
okay because when you load those
airplanes with 400 kilos of cocaine then
the range of it drops right so you put
extra gas and then you got you be able
to land from Bolivia non-stop tuna co2
or Columbia and we're cocaine go like
what part of the plane you put the give
to Heidi or just not double the bladders
yeah double back here yeah yeah oh yeah
no we had every country pay off okay we
got it everybody wherever wherever the
airplane flew over somebody that Reno
radar was paid off and so president was
paid off that make sure the guys are in
the radar was paid off so yeah we did it
man we flew like like was just
delivering toys for huh you know go
ahead check out their sockets so we so
I'm going and then the other alternative
breaks and then we crash-landed in
Panama right so you see a copy if you
see a picture of my book the plane
landed like this we should have all died
when the plane lands in Panama
immediately the police came and got
caught in a tree or something
no no we ran out of fuel and we
crash-landed think I was a banana field
that had just been cut days earlier so
it was all like rains a mushy so were
like like mud so the plane just died
otherwise you could have exploded so I
jumped out the guy My partner got that I
hired to transport it for me Harold
he jumps I said blow the airplane take
the flare gun in this blow the freaking
airplane and I'm like oh hell no way no
I said dude there's seven million
dollars of cocaine in that airplane
he says George you can make it again
build the airplane or you can go to jail
I said I mean I'm in my country I Drive
anybody on one out here I am worried
about going to jail in South America
right so the police come and I had a
sense
I briefly had a false bottom and I
always kept 100 I travel with $100,000
all the time and I took out that's the
mistake I made I took out doing it but I
should have just told the guy what was
going on and say hey here's $10,000
which is today's money 200,000 togather
primate $10 a week a month he would have
guarded that airplane with his life I
said look we crashed we were looking for
some land to buying we had probably
nothing we crashed and he couldn't go in
the airplane because we had to literally
jump off so he had to bring a ladder to
be able to go in the air right right so
I felt good about that and I said hey
take is my passports can you stamp them
so that we came in legally take us to a
hotel I'm gonna make some phone calls so
I can get someone tomorrow morning from
Costa Rica
so Costa Rica was only about ten miles
from there and we had spent over a
million dollars to get that president
elected in Costa Rica so we have a lot
of power in Costa Rica we knew be
totally safe we can we'll take the
cocaine right in a car right through the
board how did you spend ten million
dollars to get a president elected
because that you end up having all kinds
of connections all over the world right
everybody knows somebody see that the
people wonder like how do you bribe
somebody everybody has the best friend
and the best friend the best friend and
you can always get to somebody you know
like they'll say money corrupts and
absolute corrupts and absolute money
corrupts absolutely well that's it I
mean when people are making nothing and
people need money like well today so
close to building now to run for
president showed up in Bloomberg and pay
for your own election right you you got
people giving you a lot of money they're
not giving your oh my god they like you
because you're pretty and you talk nice
they get a lot of money cuz you gonna do
what they say and that's the bottom line
right we wanted to buy the Playboy Hotel
in Costa Rica so because it was a good
way to launder money so I knew that we
had no problem so we went to the hotel I
made a phone call and they sent a car in
the following morning so I went to
police station to pick out the passport
and when I went to police station to
pick out the passport I saw this
Gringo's I'm like we're [ __ ]
I said yeah problem FBI it was dead head
of the DEA for Panama
it was the Consul General for Panama
and it was the heddles g24 panama they
come and they had all the cocaine in a
table just like this and it puts behind
it they took pictures of us and i said i
want to talk to my attorney
good luck and they're like dude you're
in Panama this is a Napoleonic law we
can keep your seven years we are you
talking to anybody I'm fake sure say
sooner or later somebody big is gonna
come see me I'm convinced of that
exactly the following day the Attorney
General comes and when the Attorney
General comes I said look don't waste my
time
I got two questions how much money to
buy the coke came back how much money to
leave he's like no riego ray sold the
cocaine $250,000 you leave 104 you fifty
freeze of the other one I'm like okay so
take this number and this code call this
number
yeah and I told the code to get and I
said tomorrow you had the money here and
then sure enough two days later he comes
he says everything set we're gonna take
you to Panama City how did that work how
do you how do you make a phone call from
Nicaragua and get someone they did from
Panama from Panama and what are the
United States they wired money no
someone fluid someone flew cash the next
day Berlin we talked about 1979 so you
had someone ready to go on call at all
times to deliver money anywhere in the
world we had we had all kinds of
emergency ah okay programs right so like
for one wing we went to deliver a car
yeah we always had a suicide car which
meant that if a cop is following you and
you got the cocaine your car yeah on the
suicide car I'm to ram your car and
destroy you and take me to jail for what
are you on but nothing's gonna happen to
it okay so we had all kind of
contingency plans right okay and then we
had all kinds of codes at that time
remember just doing this time there's no
cell phones this is all dial phones you
know and in in satellite phones and the
number that they would call it's a
satellite and when they call that number
no one is supposed to call
number unless any of us major the major
people new guy says you were in deep
trouble
got it okay so whoever had that he was
given that coat and told where he knew
what he had to deliver where how much
money and to who that's it so so yeah so
anyway it happened I asked so you can
look at the gonna take you Panama City
they're gonna rough you up make it look
good for the DEA and you're going on to
Costa Rica
show me the airplane tickets everything
ready I made the mistake and I go back
and I tell Harold info other pilots
don't worry man I just bribed the
Attorney General we're outta here in two
days today's came they picked us up flew
it to Panama City private jet everything
beautiful and we get to Panama City and
there's a room big conference room
nothing for shares up against the wall
so they it tells to sit down we sit down
and also on the opener don't they bring
this Panamanian kid completely naked
handcuffed probably about 5 190 500
pounds they threw him on the floor feet
handcuffed hands handcuffed and they
took a broomstick and stuck it up his
ass and blood just splatter all over the
place until the kids just I thought they
killed him and they looked at us and
later I says we caught him with ten
pounds of marijuana in other words we
guys you got it with 250 kilos of
cocaine I think what's happening this
big old to big old Georgia pilots well
six two one six three the minute they
saw that will tell will tell because the
story was that and I was just flying I
was gonna meet with the Sandinistas and
I was supposed to give him the suitcases
that I thought had guns and they were
pay me $25,000 which would have been
nothing in Latin America right I didn't
know that was cocaine in there so if we
stuck to the story would have been no
problem because we crash-landed in
Panama we didn't land in Panama to do
something Panama so the Turner was gonna
leave us was the fact he had no
jurisdiction over us right but when the
minute that we that he saw that they
told him number one not only
if George was the biggest drug dealer in
America he's just right the Attorney
General and that [ __ ] hit the fan
they sent him to Miami and it took me
and Harold her boss and it took us in a
dungeon for 27 28 days and they torture
us day and night day and night to the
point that for five years every time I
went to bathroom I piss blood they would
just come in and just beat us that we
pass out they would throw gasoline on us
cattle prod to my testicles I would jump
this high and somehow pass out but it's
interesting as I tell you about mindset
one of those time that I pass out I had
this vision and the vision is I'm
shaving and I see my son my youngest son
who was only six months old but he's
about seven or eight and he comes in
he's crying and he's like I'm like why
you kinds worry he's like dad my friend
said that my father's not a man and I
said that day I'm gonna dying this son
of a [ __ ] but I'm not giving him
nothing
[Laughter]